et l'europe pointe à nouveau du doigt
facebook
la data protection cognition irlandaise
l'équivalent de la cnil en france menace
le réseau social de bloquer les
transferts de données de européens vers
les états unis
la commission qui agit pour l'ensemble
de l'union européenne jugent illégales
les transmissions de ses data vers
l'oncle sam
google et amazon sont également
concernés par cette décision pour
facebook il s'agit d'une procédure sans
fondement on en parle avec anthony bem
avocat spécialiste du numérique
bonjour automne ibm merci de répondre à
nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
pourquoi cette menace du régulateur
irlandais en quoi ces transferts de
données d'européens vers les états unis
posent problème en effet ça fait des
mois maintenant que l'union européenne
planche sur la question de la
réglementation du transfert des données
personnelles vers les états unis
il ne faut pas oublier que les gaffes à
les grands sites internet google apple
facebook ou s'agissant de l'europe leurs
serveurs en irlande
c'est à dire qu'ils ont choisi
volontairement l'irlande comme un
paradis juridiques voire même fiscale
dans certains cas pour bénéficier de la
réglementation la plus favorable et au
récemment il ya quelques jours l'irlande
la cnil irlandaise vient de dire à
facebook attention attention nous allons
bloquer les données personnelles des
utilisateurs européens vers les états
unis
c'est à dire concrètement facebook ne
pourra pu récolter les données
personnelles des utilisateurs du réseau
en europe
et l'on sait que facebook ne gagne de
l'argent véritablement qu'au travers de
l'utilisation de l'exploitation
commerciale des données personnelles des
utilisateurs et donc cette décision est
extrêmement important importante qu'à à
l'été l'accord qui avait été passé entre
l'union européenne et les etats unis
s'agissant de la réglementation des
données personnelles était invalidée par
la cour de justice de l'union européenne
et là on voit il ya quelques jours que
c'est l'irlande qui s'y met cette fois
ci pour bloquer le transfert des données
personnelles via les états unis comment
protéger les citoyens européens
concrètement et quelle marge de
manoeuvre juridique vous qui êtes avocat
pour pour l'europe alors jusqu'au
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il faut pas oublier
que le droit de la terre allaitent et
est adroit en gestation c'est un droit
qui nous vaut les réseaux sociaux n'ont
qu'à peine 10 ans d'existence et donc le
droit prend du temps à mettre en place
un cadre une réglementation applicable
en matière d'internet la meilleure
sanction qui permettra aux internautes
de faire en sorte que leur vie privée
leurs données personnelles soient
protégés ce seront les sanctions
financières
il ne faut pas oublier que par exemple
la cnil irlandaise aura la possibilité
de sanctionner facebook
le cas échéant en prononçant des amendes
et il faut pas oublier que 5% du chiffre
d'affaires de facebook en amande
correspondra à 2,4 milliards de dollars
et au travers de cette amende est au
travers de l'impossibilité pour facebook
de récolter les données personnelles des
utilisateurs du marché européen
facebook comme tous les autres sites
devront se mettre au diapason tout ou
tard et au delà des sanctions
financières qui on venait d'évoquer les
conditions générales d'utilisation d'un
service ne sont pas suffisantes pour
alerter l'utilisateur non à plusieurs
reprises différentes jurisprudence ont
considéré que les conditions générales
des réseaux sociaux ne sont pas
susceptibles d'être opposés aux
utilisateurs pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'il y a aucune garantie qu'ils
ne les élus elles font des dizaines de
pages joël sont-elles compréhensible
parfois en contradiction avec les droits
et je reviens ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le droit à internet est un droit
qui est complexe pourquoi parce qu'il
met en en conflit plusieurs droits
nationaux et voit par exemple qu'on a le
droit américain d'à côté on aurait le
droit français ou le droit irlandais de
l'autre et puis on a le droit européen
et tant que haut niveau international le
droit d'internet n'aura pas erré été
réglementée au travers de traités voire
de conventions internationales aucune
réglementation efficace ne pourra avoir
lieu
dernière question anthony même les
les gaffes as qui peuvent demander des
contreparties en gros au delà du
juridique dont on est en train de parler
en ce moment mais ce qui aura pas des
négociations en coulisses j'ai reçu en
permanence en réalité facebook twitter
instagram google facebook ont des
relations que ce soit pas leurs
dirigeants par leurs représentants
juridiques avec les autorités politiques
locales
mais on voit bien que ces autorités
politiques locales ne savent pas rien
parce qu'en réalité comme je vous le
disais c'est au niveau international que
cela ce règlement et il s'agissant de
l'europe
on voit qu'on a un puissant adversaire
aux états unis au travers tant de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
que de l'irlande qui viennent de s'y
mettre aujourd'hui au travers de cinq
mille merci beaucoup anthony même pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat spécialiste du droit du
numérique